John Barry NBA analyst for the
mothership set to fly to Cleveland as we
get ready for Game three he joins us now
John how are you this morning what do
you say dad well I'm just trying to
understand concussion protocol here in
the NBA and I didn't know if you ever
had a concussion probably but I don't
hear you weren't good enough for them to
care partly that and partly the NBA I
don't think we really address the
subject of concussions but when it comes
to kevin love and being in Kentucky you
expect him to playing game 3 uh I don't
think so yeah I mean I know he flew with
him yesterday I'd know that would be the
easier way to do it he to be on a plane
where he could walk around lie down do
whatever you had to do um but I I mean
the way he walked out what people are
saying I would imagine it's got to be a
couple day process at least are you go
back home you expect the bench to play a
little better the home crowd but but why
would this change dramatically that
Cleveland all of a sudden finds out how
to play basketball um I don't know that
it will uh I don't think the worries are
played their best basketball either
that's what's scary I mean they haven't
had to use courier Thompson really to
have a big game to win I mean it was
draymond Green and Game two it was Shaun
Livingston and Barbosa off the bench in
Game one so I believe the Warriors can
play better they they played sloppy they
turn the basketball over and not played
their best Cleveland's got to find
something on both ends of the floor
making it shoot the ball you know
they're the three ball is not there I
mean everything they did in the first
three rounds of the Eastern Conference
they know they not been able to do any
of it and so I guess that's an
indictment of the Eastern Conference
yeah I don't know if we build up like
this false power here with Cleveland
Cleveland is a good team but man there's
a big difference between the the best
team defending champs in the second best
team well maybe it's oklahoma city's the
second best team in the NBA and the
Spurs might be the third but I'm just
surprised that Cleveland can't find a
rhythm can't find an offense it doesn't
feel like they know exactly if they want
to be small ball or big ball you're not
supposed to get to the finals and still
be scratching your head trying to search
for answers here John you know it's very
surprising i mean if you go back and
look last year they had a 2-1 lead with
LeBron James and you and I and in
whoever I mean he had nobody with them
and I know his numbers were crazy but uh
you know he's got Kyrie Irving he had
Kevin Love & Game one you know 20
minutes of Kevin Levin game two he
really wasn't effective at all either uh
so I don't know why you can't even
really be in ball games if this doesn't
make sense the offenses just kind of
lebron lebron by himself counting it or
its Kyrie Irving pounding it and all the
ball moment all the things that they've
done they've not been able to do in the
Warriors have to get some credit i love
the way they're defending they're trying
to post LeBron it and I liken this to a
rookie quarterback in the NFL getting
all these different looks from a defense
and they are throwing different looks
they're double-teaming from the top
they're coming from the bottom they're
coming off first dribble coming off the
past and they've got LeBron confused if
you you watch LeBron a lot you see him
particularly in the eastern playoff just
zoom and passes cross court right on the
money to three-point shooters I don't
recall seeing any in this series i think
the word got a great job of disguising
their defense is LeBron better without
stars around him as strange as that's
going to sound well his numbers are
going to be better uh but in the end can
you win by yourself and I think it was a
perfect example of that last year in the
finals that first for three or four
games he was absolutely incredible but
he tired out and it's just too much of a
load for one guy to beat a good
basketball team but does he need to be
more selfish right you can't put up 17
shots he's got a he's got to still get
25 shots at least he's got to you know
put somebody and found trouble get to
the line
and I really thought that they I don't
want to say that they just gave up but
they certainly lost their
competitiveness in the fourth quarter of
Game two you know I hate to use work
with but I mean this is LeBrons team
this is your moment you want to show
you're the most valuable player this
isn't the way you go down right well you
know it goes back to the conversation
that he's more magic johnson than he is
Michael Jordan right I mean he would
rather be a facilitator in the end then
be a guy that takes 30 35 shots how many
times michael jordan Take 30 35 shots
all the time you know LeBron James I
would love to know how many times in a
game he's taken over 30 shots I bet it's
a handful yeah but magic was a
cold-blooded killer too so he was a
facilitator but you know he either way
though in a different way he was never a
guy that was going yeah I he had the one
game what he had 40 points we played
center again Sixers an 81 you know or
whatever that was 80 but other than that
I mean you ever remember huge scoring
nights for magic we didn't heal the
aggressive you know well you can be
aggressive in a way that you yeah you
did the pass is the only thing you can
do but LeBron he's in a post em curry
I'm in the post in Game one four or five
times and he kicked it out the
three-point shooter now that's not good
basketball I want him shooting the
basketball when he's in the paint when
he has anybody on him much less Steph
Curry John buried the mothership calling
the NBA Finals for ESPN radio more
likely to be a four-game sweep or go six
games Rick what would happen to five
well i'm takin fine done we go right to
fit yes I'm because I it's either
Cleveland losses in Game three and
they'll mail it in in Game four or
they'll win in Game three and then pull
out a victory another victory make it go
six well I'm not going all the way to 6
i'm going to five if Cleveland wins Game
three all even if lately which games for
area oh you want to go back home but you
know Sam Cisco golf club and
oh man tracks up and yeah well yeah
let's know but I said five before the
city to this series and it all comes
down when you're down to zero the game
three and you're right if they don't win
game three very difficult for cleveland
to get up for game 4 and it's more than
likely a sweet keep talking about
lebron's legacy you know that if you go
two and four in the NBA final I mean it
does it matter if if he ends up two and
six in the NBA finals in his career I
know I I don't think you put it on him I
mean I don't know if you saw Jerry West
comments but uh obviously Jerry's on his
side since Jerry was one and eight yeah
um but no I don't put it on him the only
one I would say in these finals that
he's played in was the Dallas series
that he was not good I mean I that was a
guy didn't recognize if you remember
that series he was just a deer in
headlights and it was the pressure that
got to him and he he didn't play
basketball worth a darn and other than
that no I don't put it on him he gotta
remember you and I work together in 07
that was the worst team ever in the
finals yeah the Cleveland team yep I
that's his fault that they don't win
well I think now that he's orchestrated
teams it's different then you know what
he did against San Antonio was
incredible just to get there that's
right that's a credit to him but I think
it's a knock when you look at you
orchestrated lineups and you you
maneuvered you partnered with buddies
you got coach a coach fired then it's
more on you now so you know he's got to
take some knocks with this okay so
you're saying outside of the basketball
itself not him the player him being the
guy behind the moon yeah yeah okay well
yeah so did did he not want Andrew
Wiggins I guess he wanted to get the
kevin love Trey done so i would this can
be if they had Andrew Wiggins I think
that's the warrior they would be better
with Andrew Wiggins than he would Kevin
Love you think so yes Wiggins can play
both ways I mean he sees a transition
guy he can defend he's better suited to
today
is NBA yeah okay well you know so the
Warriors are pretty good small bowl too
I don't mean to yell at you all right
i'm not i'm ok ok but I my dad but I'm
saying the so will I saw a number that
the small lineup for the the Cleveland
Cavaliers right now just getting
annihilated by the small lineup of the
Warriors so why do teams continue to do
this I know okc did it a little bit but
OKC's really good they have a lot better
players than Cleveland that are around
their stars but what why why do you play
small I don't understand like teams try
to do this I said the same thing from
the beginning don't try to be golden
State because you'll never be better
than Golden State in that style so do
something different that's why I loved
Oklahoma City they played a different
style and Catherine Adams yes they
played big baby but they had a small
lineup to that was good but for the most
part yes the big lineup they powered the
Warriors they beat him on the glass they
beat him on the interior and they should
have won that series let's be honest you
know they were the better team for more
more minutes than the Warriors were any
pressure on the NBA to have their stars
playing the Olympics like how's this
going to play out with guys backing out
of the Olympics I I don't think so I
mean do real true NBA fans care about
the Olympics as far as basketball
because it was always the the college
kids prior you know prior to what 92
when they started this well I think we
only care about the end result just when
it doesn't matter who's there Yeah right
right but Arnold's are they going to get
criticized if we don't win the gold do
then guys like Steph Curry and whoever
else doesn't play do they then get
criticized III don't think so i really
don't i don't know i just for me if i
was always a bigger fan and obviously 92
was unbelievable the greatest team ever
assembled but after that I really lost
interest in it I never really watch
after 92 I liked it better when it was
the the college kids yeah I like the
amateur stat
but you know we panicked in 72 when the
Soviets beat the the US team and then
we're like we're you know if this is our
game and we're we're losing a gold medal
here and we all are our prides at stake
here then we ended up beating everybody
by 40 and then we're like okay or to
restore it here yeah I'd much rather
have us go in and compete against these
teams with younger kids I don't know yet
you know get get a feel good story out
of this instead of just how many did we
win by 30 20 what's wrong with us well I
think we can still you know feel the
team that should be able to go there and
win you might have to suit up John uh
it's in Brazil I'll go it's all about
you hey safe travels to Cleveland always
great to talk to you stay out of trouble
thanks but all right that's John bearing
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience